so with part two on our discussion of
miss marvel or Carol Danvers we're gonna
be covering a lot of stuff in a very
short amount of time and so if any of
this doesn't make a whole lot of sense
to you then let me know and I'll do the
best that I can to explain a little bit
further in the comments section
but with issue number 19 of course we
had talked about how Marvel had
explained to us the idea of how it was
that Carol Danvers had gained her powers
of how it was that she had become Miss
Marvel and then of course the two
characters had converged into one
whereby they were now a cohesive unit
and so with issue number 20 Marvel was
attempting to move away from the idea of
Carol Danvers being more or less a copy
of Captain Marvel and decided to give
her a new outfit a totally new design
but the problem here was that with Carol
Danvers the damage had for the most part
already been done a lot of the male
readers of Marvel Comics were already
tied into other characters spider-man
Captain America The Incredible Hulk and
Iron Man and so a lot of them didn't
identify with Carol Danvers the readers
who did those who were women had looked
at Carol Danvers and had seen that for
the most part she was just given to us
as a copy of Captain Marvel and so they
were turned off by the character and so
with issue number 25 of Miss Marvel vol
1 the series was canceled and she was
moved on to the to the team of The
Avengers now for the most part with the
Avengers she had kind of just puttered
along as a background character she
really didn't have a whole lot of
notoriety but she really came to the
spotlight with a story in a vendor's
issue number number 200 and this is
considered by many to be one of the most
controversial comic books to have ever
been made in Marvel Comics to such a
degree the Marvel had actually retracted
the basis for this and they had more or
less treated it as though this story had
never happened and what we saw with
Avengers number 200 is that Miss Marvel
as part of the team had suddenly become
pregnant and no one had really known how
no one knew how it was that this had
taken place but over the course of a day
or so she had gone from the initial
stages of pregnancy
- coming to term - actually having the
child and over the course of a day the
child had grown from a I guess a newborn
baby to a full-grown adult and the way
that Marvel had explained this was by
giving us the character Marcus immortus
who was the son of a previous villain
that had been introduced to us named
immortus and what Marcus immortus tells
us is that with his father with the
character immortus he of course existing
in limbo was a person who was the master
of time but by virtue of his location
and his powers time didn't really exist
and so he had simply just existed
endlessly but along the way he had come
to this understanding that he needed
more in his life that he needed some
kind of a purpose and so what he did is
he had taken a woman for his own a
random person that he had found and with
the two of them had conceived Marcus
immortus but as time progressed immortus
eventually vanished and Marcus immortus
ran into the same situation that his
father had that he liked his father
before him needed something to make the
time pass needed something to make
things more interesting to give his life
purpose and so what are you done is he
had kidnapped Carol Danvers and when he
did he had used the combination of his
father's technology as well as some
abilities that he had inherited to
effectively woo carol danvers to
manipulate the very facets of time to
create or I guess to bring beings to her
like William Shakespeare and so the
whole basis of this was to get her to
fall in love with him which she did and
the two of them conceived but the whole
basis of this conception was
rationalized by Marcus immortus in that
he couldn't simply just transfer himself
to the earth-616 universe because if he
did he would presumably die at a very
fast pace and so the argument was that
if he had been conceived and born into
limbo then he could be conceived and
bore be born into the earth-616 universe
and so what he had done is impregnated
himself within the body of Carol Danvers
now one of the reasons why this was so
highly criticized is because in an
article called the rape of Miss Marvel
by Carol a Strickland which of course
the link will be in the description she
had made the case that what
gone on here was tantamount to getting a
woman drunk and then having sexual
intercourse with her but Carol Danvers
because her mind had been altered
because she wasn't really aware of what
the true motivations were of Marcus
immortus or because her mind had been
warped to the extent that she was more
or less being duped that she couldn't
consciously admit or consciously agree
to having sex with him and so he had in
fact in effect he use his powers and use
technology to rape her now of course
this isn't really something that's up
for the debate of whether it's right or
wrong this is simply just a matter of
perspective but this story had such a
major backlash among the female
community that Marvel had gone on to
wipe the entire concept to more or less
remove the entire story and to treat it
as though it didn't exist and so with
this Marvel did it in several stages
Marvel did this in a couple different
ways the first way was with Avengers
Avengers annual issue number 10 and 1981
and what they did was they introduced a
conflict between rogue and Miss Marvel
and this is one of the stories a rogue
is actually most well known for what had
happened here was that mystique had come
up with the idea to eliminate Miss
Marvel but she intended to use rogue
however rogue for the most part was
perceived as not being up to the task
but because rogue had overheard the plan
of mystique because she'd overheard the
plan of her mother she sought out to
pursue Miss Marvel in an effort to
demonstrate that she was a very capable
person and so is Brogan miss Marvel had
fought across the landscape as time
progressed as a conflict had moved
forward rogue had eventually I guess
absorbed both the mind and the powers of
Carol Danvers and with absorbing the
mind and the powers of Carol Danvers two
things happened the first thing is that
Carol Danvers went into a catatonic
state but the second thing is that rogue
had to constantly deal with the battle
the mental battle between her
personality and the personality of Carol
Danvers something that would go on for
quite some time but when Carol Danvers
eventually reawakened she of course had
her memories restored but she was unable
to tap into her powers and so for the
most part she was relegated as a
powerless character and so what Marvel
did is with uncanny x-men issue number
164 they had revamped her and Mae
a character called binary and what they
had done with this in kind of this final
phase of attempting to make her a new
character was to have her join the x-men
and a star Ferenc adventure and with
this story she has she found herself
kidnapped and manipulated by an alien
race called the brood which had chosen
her because of her unique physiology of
both Kree and human and so because of
this she was endowed with nearly godlike
powers in the sense that she can
manipulate cosmic energy by tapping into
a white hole but she also had vast
strength or I guess a vast physical
powers more so than she ever had before
and what the problem here was that
despite the fact that people weren't
avid readers of her they were used to
her character being a certain way and so
she wasn't very very popular among a lot
of accounting book readers and so what
Marvel did is they eventually retracted
the character of binary and had Miss
Marvel we take back her uniform and
eventually join The Avengers again and
for the most part she would again
continue to remain a background
character she would stay this way for
quite some time in fact until the events
of the house of M and with the house of
M what this did is it gave a lot of
women and comic-book readers The Carol
Danvers they were looking for because
what it did is it had taken her away
from this character who was suffering
from identity crises who was kind of
being tossed into these humbling
circumstances where she seemed always
out of control and made her a forefront
character with the house of M she was
the most popular character on the planet
Earth in that alternate reality she was
thrown back to her roots of being strong
of being confident of being a very
capable superhero and a lot of fans
latched on to this a lot of fans loved
this element of Carol Danvers and Marvel
saw this and so what they did is they
capitalized on this even further with
the Civil War storyline and that's why
we saw Carol Danvers despite the fact
that she had a limited solo series in
the during the Civil War events had
become a forefront character she was for
the most part the second most
recognizable character on the side of
iron man throughout the entire conflict
especially after Spiderman had defected
and so what Marvel did is when they
looked at the success of her character
both in the House of M and in civil war
and the portrayal of her character in
those events they decided to revamp her
character with the Marvel now event and
again the marble now is simply just
Marvel going back and taking the origins
of the characters and bringing them back
so that people who are new to comics
wouldn't have to read through 60 years
of Thor comics in order to understand
who Thor is they wouldn't have to go
back to the original Captain Marvel
comics to know who Miss Marvel is they
could simply just start with Miss Marvel
issue number one and that's what they
did with Marvel now except what they had
done with this comic is they had
introduced the idea of Carol Danvers
becoming Captain Marvel and the way they
did this I think was really intelligent
and was really really unique
they had a Captain America of all people
pitched the idea to Carol Danvers Carol
Danvers initially didn't actually want
to take over the role of Captain Marvel
for her she had looked at Captain Marvel
as a character she looked at him as
something to look up to but Marvel did
this very cautiously when they initially
came up with this idea of Carol Danvers
taking over the role of Captain Marvel
they went back to her roots they went
back to her heritage they asked
themselves the question what was it that
made Carol Danvers so popular in the
first place she was a strong female
character she had looked up to Captain
Marvel her entire basis for becoming
Miss Marvel was to fight alongside
Captain Marvel as an equal which
mirrored the feminist ideas at the time
that women wanted to be equal to men and
so when Marvel pitched this idea again
she was a little reluctant but after
talking to spider-man and various other
individual she decided to accept the
mantle of Captain Marvel from here we're
gonna go ahead and bring this video to
an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys later peace